あは
足腰巌の料理教室へようこそ
今回の料理も私足腰いわおが務めさせていただきます
よろしくお願いいたします
皆様はアポロチョコというお菓子ご存知でしょうか？
こちらにあるんですけれども
まあ有名なお菓子ですよね？
イチゴの形になっているチョコレート　一粒取ってみましょう
おおーこんな感じですね
親指の先よりもちょっと小さいサイズの感じになってますね
味が分からーん
おい！分からんぞ味が！
まあわからんこともないです
分からんこともないんですけれども
小さい
小さいんですよ
めっちゃおいしいのはわかるんですけれども
あの僕身長が高いんで
なんか僕に見合ったサイズのアポロチョコを作った方がおいしく食べれるんじゃないかと思いまして
小さすぎて味がちょっとよくわからないんで
今日はアポロチョコを作っていきたいと思います
とりあえず作るものとしてチョコがめっちゃ必要
板チョコめっちゃ準備しました
アポロチョコの形として一番大事な部分がこのピンク色の部分なんで
なんかイチゴのチョコがあんま売ってなくて
結構取り寄せたんですけど
イチゴチョコ2キロ分準備いたしました
アポロチョコの難しいところは
形なんですよね
あの独特なチョコの形　素材があるだけで実現するのは難しいと思ったんですけれども
私の仮説が正しければ
ビニール傘があれば作れると思うんですよ
皆さんビニール傘知ってますか？
ビニール傘ってあれじゃん？
アポロチョコやん？
ビニール傘の半開きの状態とアポロチョコは同じ形をしているので
では早速作っていこう
では行こう！